[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture en
direct sur tv 78 voici les titres le
monde culturel a directement impacté par
les annonces du chef de l'état un
nouveau coup de massue pour les théâtres
et salles de spectacles qui vont devoir
respecter le couvre-feu de 21h les
acteurs locaux en temps de se mobiliser
ouverture exceptionnelle d'un cabinet de
curiosités à dampierre pour les vacances
de la toussaint le domaine vous invite à
découvrir le musée d'histoire naturelle
du duc de luynes une collection pour la
première fois exposé au public
le 44e salon d'automne d'andrésy a
débuté samedi dernier
organisé par l'amicale des beaux-arts de
la ville et l'exposition comptait 22
artistes au programme peinture à l'huile
et sculptures ou encore collage 120
oeuvres étaient à découvrir je vous le
disais en titre tout à l'heure le monde
culturel a été directement impactés par
les annonces du chef de l'état dans la
soirée de mercredi 14 octobre un nouveau
coup de massue pour les théâtres et
salles de spectacles qui vont devoir
respecter le couvre-feu de 21h pour
l'heure ils tentent de s'adapter pour
maintenir une offre est resté ouvert
théâtres et salles de spectacles
vont-ils fermés ou bien s'adapter
les mesures gouvernementales annoncées
mercredi 14 octobre vont une nouvelle
fois impacté le monde culturel qui
commençait tout juste à reprendre
adaptation des horaires ou encore report
des spectacles les acteurs culturels
locaux
en temps de se mobiliser évidemment il
ya des spectacles qu'on va pas pouvoir
se présenter mais on va maintenir le
théâtre ouvert et présenter le maximum
de spectacles dans les contraintes qui
nous sont imposées aujourd'hui la la
saison en cours celle qui vient de
commencer en septembre
tout aura lieu s'il faut reporter on
reportera mais les gens pourront voir
tous les spectacles qu'on a proposé on
en aura pas d'autres temps que ceux là
n'auront pas été lus théâtres et salles
de spectacles compte fermer leurs portes
à 20h30
objectif permettre aux spectateurs de
regagner leur domicile avant 21h en
semaine c'est plus dur quand même
donc en semaine on on se heurte à la
durée la durée des spectacles
c'est à dire comment on peut pas non
plus dire mardi ou vendredi à 18h
fendirent le beaucoup de gens
travaillent
il faut qu il est temps de quitter leur
travail de se restaurer d'arrivée la
salle de spectacle je pense qu'on va
essayer 19 heures on met ça pose
clairement la question des spectacles y
ont plus d'une heure trente un côté
économie les établissements publics et
privés sont impactés de façon différente
les théâtres privés repose en grande
partie sur les recettes de la
billetterie
tandis que les théâtres publics et
bénéficie de subventions dans l'immédiat
on est dans une situation un peu un peu
moins catastrophique que des des
théâtres privés
mais la question est de savoir lorsqu'on
va avoir 200 300 400 mille euros de
recettes de billetterie en moins au mois
de juin prochain
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
programmer la la saison suivante
en juillet le ministère de la culture a
annoncé une baisse moyenne du chiffre
d'affaires de 25% en 2020 par rapport à
2019 soit un déficit de 22 milliards
d'euros des acteurs culturels yvelinois
qui se sont donc exprimés le lendemain
des mesures gouvernementales annoncé le
mercredi 14 octobre dernier est soutenue
par roselyne bachelot il espérait une
dérogation pour pouvoir fermer leurs
portes à 21h et permettre aux
spectateurs de rentrer en montrant tout
simplement le billet et permettre
d'avoir le billet en tant que
justificatifs
vendredi le premier ministre jean castex
a déclaré qu'il n'était pas favorable
alors où en sont-ils comment
s'adapte-t-il célia 400 go est avec nous
sur le plateau pour en parler mon sens
il ya ronsard alors quels événements ont
été annulés ou reportés finalement alors
il y à quelques événements justement
malheureusement kim ont dû être annulés
à maurepas il n'y aura finalement pas
l'ouverture de la saison culturelle les
spectacles de jean luc lemoine et de
johnny montreuil sont reportés à la
saison prochaine comme la nuit des
châteaux qui devait avoir lieu au
domaine de dampierre c'est un spectacle
de lumières qui devait donc avoir lieu
dans les jardins de monsieur de notre
île est lui aussi reporté
malheureusement
tout comme la soirée spéciale halloween
prévue mercredi 21 octobre à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet par contre les
animations et les ateliers restent eux
maintenue en journée bien sûr et puis
les concerts bach haendel rameau génie
de leur castro baroque à l'opéra royal
de versailles sont également annulés ce
spectacle était prévue le 6 novembre à
20h et j'imagine qu'il ya des événements
qui vont être avancée c'est le cas pour
la nuit de la guitare qui se déroule
samedi 24 octobre au pecq
initialement prévue pour débuter à 18h30
finalement la ville a décidé d'avancer
les horaires pour respecter bien sûr le
couvre-feu et débuté donc à 16h30
pareil pour toutes les représentations
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
celle qui devait avoir lieu à 19h30 au à
20h30 ont été avancées finalement à 19
heures et c'est un moment c'est
compliqué pour les cabaret oui c'est un
coup dur pour eux sachant qu'ils doivent
toujours s'adapter aux contraintes
sanitaires alors le cabaret du bout du
bout des prêts à cerner la ville a
décidé de lancer une nouvelle formule
pour ne pas céder à la fermeture de
l'établissement
les vendredi soir et samedi soir sont
passés à des spectacles apéro donc à
18h30 accueil avec des pizzas justement
en mode apéro une petite boisson ou
commencerait le spectacle à 19h15 pour
une fin à 24 ans voilà pour que les gens
puissent contrer chez eux
le cabaret du bout des prix anormalement
200 places assises
il les avait déjà réduit au nombre de
places à 100 durant la crise sanitaire
et maintenant avec la règle des six
personnes maximum établi par le
président de la république
cette jauge est passé à 80 personnes une
règle de 10 sa roue entrée 10 personnes
sur la même table là on est passé à 6
donc comme les distances sociales sont
d'un mètre entre les chaises on a aussi
maintenant six plus une règle d'un mètre
entre chaque table ce qui fait que notre
jauge petit à petit se réduit quoi
compliquer et puis il ya aussi à des
événements nationaux dont l'issue est
encore incertaine comme la nuit
européenne des musées
qui était prévu le 16 mai 2020 déjà qui
a déjà été reporté à cause de la crise
sanitaire donc pour le 14 novembre
alors quid du maintien ou non à des
événements dans les yvelines
la réponse ces prochaines semaines merci
célia get on go nous avoir éclairé un
peu plus sur le sujet on retrouve bien
sûr et la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle émission en direct avec plaisir
les cinémas eux aussi sont impactés par
le couvre-feu ils vont devoir revoir
leurs horaires de projection les films
longs notamment vont être compliqués a
programmé les séances de 20h devrait
être supprimée de façon à ce que les
cinémas fermés leurs portes avant 21h
elle l'exemple avec luc beaucamp
directeur du ciné 7 au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
je pense qu'on va décaler les sens
effectivement plus tôt c'est à dire on
va peut-être organiser les dernières
séances vers 18h30 19h de façon à ce
qu'à 21h les cinémas soit fermée il ya
forcément une séance qui va sauter
environ le week-end puisque nous on fait
dans un 18 heures le week-end mais
uniquement le week-end donc maintenant
je pense qu'on va en faire toute la
semaine
par contre c'est les séances de 20h30
20h45 qui vont sauter puisque il est
absolument impossible de les tenir dans
les délais
prescrit par le couvre-feu quoi le 44e
salon d'automne d'andrésy a débuté
samedi 17 octobre organisée par
l'amicale à des beaux-arts à
l'exposition était visible à l'espace
julien green
au programme peinture à l'huile et
sculptures ou encore collage 120 oeuvres
étaient à découvrir mélanie poké s est
rendu sur place
un 44e salon d'automne à andrésy pour
faire connaître l'art de la peinture et
de la poésie
l'amicale des beaux-arts à sélectionner
les artistes présents en amont un
événement devenu incontournable selon le
président de l'association
le salon d'andrésy devient un salon qui
est maintenant réputé donc
automatiquement dunk en contact ces
peintres parce que de bouche à oreille
des artistes ils en parlent et sax un
très beau salon et de qualité donc j'y
vienne dès qu'on les contacts ils sont
contents de venir exposer vendredi j 22
artistes ont exposé leurs oeuvres à
l'espace julien green l'événement
permettait de rencontrer le public et
d'avoir un retour sur leur travail
lloyd et
des gens avertis m'intéresse de savoir
comment ils ressentent
comment ils perçoivent les peintures les
tableaux les sujets aussi donc ça
m'intéresse de savoir
et puis d'être reconnue aussi ça fait
plaisir quand on a des dons apporte de
l'émotion de la satisfaction aux
visiteurs
[Musique]
sur place acrylique peinture à l'huile
collages ou encore sculpture au total
120 oeuvres étaient à découvrir chaque
artiste dispose et 2,5 grillé pour
exprimer son univers ils ont un bel
espace où les ogres sont sont bien
représentés normalement dans les salons
il ya une ou deux heures alors que là on
laisse vraiment l'espace pour exprimer
un travail
l'exposition devait être visible
jusqu'au 25 octobre en raison d'un
arrêté préfectoral faisant suite aux
nouvelles mesures sanitaires
l'événement a été écourtée et plusieurs
expositions ont été annulés suite à cet
arrêté préfectoral à datant du 17
octobre
il interdit et notamment les salles de
fêtes et les salles polyvalentes
d'accueillir du public dans le
département des yvelines est parmi les
expositions quand même à venir et donc
ils peuvent être maintenus le château de
breteuil fait son cinéma une collection
de jouets playmobil présenté par
dominique béthune des mises en scènes
représentant au des films seront
proposés du samedi 24 au dimanche 25
octobre de 10h à 18h et puis à
versailles la galerie moderna accueille
l'exposition l'âme des objets elle sera
visible jusqu'au lundi 2 novembre
quatorze exposants présenteront des
photos réalisées dans le cadre
d'ateliers à l'université interâges et
si vous aimez la paléontologie
l'archéologie ou encore la zoologie
pendant les vacances scolaires le
domaine de dampierre en yvelines ouvre
exceptionnellement son cabinet de
curiosités une sorte de petit musée
d'histoire naturelle
une collection pour la première fois
exposé au public
un reportage de célia get on go et va
champenois une partie d'une mâchoire
d'une baleine ou une statue représentant
le mythe d'andromède cette petite salle
fourmis de collections d'archéologie de
botanique d'anatomie et de préhistoire
dans cette vitrine
les collections de préhistoire
archéologie on est ici les collections
de paléontologie
des pièces rares inédite jamais présenté
au public
elle appartenait à la famille de luynes
propriétaire pendant plus de trois
siècles du château de dampierre
nous sommes dans la pièce principale qui
la grande pièce qui fait à peu près 400
mètres carrés qui entouré de vitrines et
au centre il ya des vitrines également
la majorité de la collection présente
des minéralogie dans cette pièce
ce sont d une collection de pierres de
toutes origines météorite pierres
précieuses fossiles plus de 6000
exemplaires de pierre sont présentés
dans cette salle également une
collection de zoologie on a des petits
mammifères belle collection anthologique
reptiles poissons et aussi animaux
sauvages viennent compléter ses
collections les visites guidées se font
sur réservation maximum cinq personnes
par visite pour respecter les consignes
sanitaires
c'est vraiment un endroit qu'une grande
grande richesse
toutes les pièces soit en mise en valeur
on apprend vraiment sûr sur la recherche
scientifique 19e et même avant la
collection de pierres de minéraux est
vraiment extraordinaire
j'imaginais pas qu'il y avait autant de
choses différentes dans le monde
ce cabinet de curiosités seulement
ouvert pendant les vacances de la
toussaint une période propice pour
inviter les familles la présentation
exceptionnelle que nous avons
aujourd'hui elle se fait évidemment par
les vacances de la toussaint puisque on
recherche un peu le mystérieux et donc
là on est en plein dedans et puis aussi
elle correspond à la fin des travaux qui
ont été réalisés par le propriétaire
pour sécuriser cet espace cette aile du
château nommé el d'astrée était en train
de s'effondrer
il fallait donc là sécurisé pour sauver
la collection le billet d'entrée pour un
adulte est de 20 euros
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture merci
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
pour un nouveau numéro en direct et
d'ici là portez vous bien
[Musique]